at this hour joe biden leads president
trump by 253 electoral votes to 213.
he's just 17 short of the 170th of the
270
he needs to clinch victory some
unresolved races in key states
will determine the outcome under the
american system that is
frequently the case you may recall back
in 2000
it all came down to florida president
george w bush
won the state and therefore the
presidency by just
537 votes of the more than 6 million
cast these now infamous paper punch card
ballots played a critical role
in making that election so difficult to
call cbs new senior political analyst
and 60 minutes correspondent john
dickerson joins us now john
uh we all remember the anxiety that
played out over
weeks in the aftermath of that election
as we know that i mean nationally it was
500 000 votes that divided the two
out of 100 million cast i think that the
split in the electoral
college vote was literally like four or
five electoral votes
it was quite small and it all came down
to florida florida was going to
determine who the president was going to
be and i think that image was of
judge robert rosenberg in broward county
who was holding up the spy glass like
sherlock holmes looking at those
i still remember that shot john yeah i
still remember it and we go
just taking it but going back one little
beat is the the
what initiated the craziness was that it
was first called for al gore and all the
networks who were in a race
back then and anthony salvanto who is
our elections director is so cautious in
part because of the scalding of that
time
everybody called it for gore and they
said it was too close to call then they
called it for bush
gore called bush and conceded then
everybody moved it back to too close to
call gore
receded the concession so it was madness
leading into this five
this five-week period of camp what did
we learn from that and
relative to today well hopefully we
learned in the press to not call states
before they're ready to go
we have learned that we are not calling
it right and that's why we're
everybody's being so cautious here
well one quick thing though is is that
um what we also learned though is in the
political process you can shape it
outside of the structure for counting
you know there was a there was a lot of
effort
in the kind of theater of public opinion
to shape the outcome
of the vote counting well let's talk
about that theater actually because
that's what i'm interested in in 2000
there was something called the brooks
brothers
riot where uh gentlemen in suits with
sort of tasseled loafers
republican operatives and lawyers
disrupted a canvassing meeting in
miami-dade county
this time around the protests are not
brooks brothers there's kind of flak
jackets and trump flags
um but how do those demonstrations
potentially impact what's going on
in these rooms and with the courts right
well as you just
focusing just on the theater of what
people are wearing it's gotten more
uh kind of hardcore the brooks brothers
riot was given that name in part because
it was operatives from out of state
trying to make it look like or pretend
that this was a grassroots uprising
the big big other difference is that
that was a recount in florida
okay that was a there was an automatic
recount process in florida
um this went beyond that um and i won't
get into the details but the votes had
been counted
what's happening with president trump is
he's asking the vote stop being counted
for the first time so that's a big
difference there
um and also everything is just so much
more tense and electrified now
than it was back then um and you see so
many more
at the time in 2000 people were crying
bloody murder on both sides but there
were norms that were
in place of politics and there was a
line between politics and
and some people would say that line was
eroded a little bit by the decision and
certainly in the line between the
supreme court
and politics because the decision of the
supreme court 5-4 by the conservatives
in favor of the republican president
that that eroded the wall between the
supreme court and politics
but where we are now is much different
and most of those walls are down it does
feel that so many people are on edge and
so
angry on both sides what does it say
this close race
say about the makeup of both parties we
are in a very
partisan moment in america the the if
you want to look at the good side look
at how many people turned out
in a pandemic and they participated
and so that's great the reason we have
elections is so we don't have fisticuffs
in the street
so and by the way all these states even
though it's taking a little time
they're doing a great job they're
counting the votes there isn't kind of
the madness of looking at hanging chads
and dimpled chads
and the systems have gotten better so
that's all good and we'll see how we
resolve it but but back to your original
point gail we're in a very very
polarized country in which people's
beliefs
line up with their parties and we have
actors the president in particular
who uses that partisanship very very
successfully to gain political power and
maintain it
that's in part what politics is but uh
unlike in previous generations people
are pushing the edges of what's
acceptable
and when you are on the losing side of
that if there's not a political way to
solve those problems people take to the
state now we could have
a democratic president and a republican
senate and a
and another form of paralysis in effect
yes a
form of paralysis or everybody says we
got to get something done so maybe we
might work together
there is the glimmer faintest glimmer
that that might happen if
only because joe biden a creature of the
senate and mitch mcconnell who will be
the republican leader they've worked
together before
i'm not saying that it's going to be
peaches and cream but they at least have
met across the table for difficult
negotiations many times before
and if you read mitch mcconnell's book
about being in the senate
he's actually quite uh he says nice
things
i remember the beer summit i i would
like to see a peaches and cream
yeah collaboration is possible john
isn't it it's possible
it is possible i don't want to go
overboard but i'm trying to kindle some
tiny
light here in the darkness dickerson
thanks very much